what that what the what the hell is down
there someone please tell that fish is
home away ok ok the bhavat worm
hands-down the most terrifying hunter in
the sea
despite being you know a worm yep you're
looking at a real live graboid from
tremors
oh these jaws are outrageous they're so
powerful but they can slice a fish in
two
oh god okay oh I mean just look at this
thing work it shouldn't even be possible
and there's no telling what's going on
in the bobbitt worms burrow mostly
because well no one has ever studied
that bit what is known is that bhavat
worms can reach a staggering ten feet
long and by now you're probably
wondering hey is the bubble worm in fact
named after those famous Bobbitt's and
their amputation incident and to that I
can say maybe unfortunately the origins
of the name are hazy but I can see the
similarities Oh No